hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast speech graphs as a tool
for psychiatric diagnosis a physicist
walk into computational psychiatry
presented by Mauro Capelli associate
professor of physics federal university
of pernambuco I'm Alexis Krause of
labyrinth and I will be our moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's laberd's is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen
dr. capella will be responding to
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2008 P
please join me in welcoming dr. Kelly I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
well okay thank you for the introduction
and for the invitation to present my
talk in this very nice conference I'm
going to be talking about speech graphs
as a tool for psychiatric diagnosis and
although I'm a physicist talk about
psychiatry the work I'm doing going to
describe has been done in close
collaboration with dr. Natalia Matta
psychiatrist with the 15 neuroscience
and professor Siddhartha Ribeiro a
neuroscientist himself both at the Brain
Institute of the federal university of
humanism our team in brazil naturally
several people were also involved along
the way so I like to start by thanking
them as well the funding agencies who
which have made this research possible
so this is the outline of my
presentation let us start by addressing
schizophrenia bipolar disorder and the
subjectivity of psychiatric diagnosis
the Priya is a chronic debilitating
mental disease of a known biological
cause with a with an estimated
prevalence of 0.6% it has some positive
psychotic symptoms like delusions and
hallucinations and negative symptoms
like lack of Gouri into behavior
emotional empathy etc bipolar disorder
on the other hand is also known as manic
depressive disorder has a slightly
larger prevalence the percent worldwide
and is characterized by episodes of an
elevated or Jaden would know as mania
usually alternated with episodes of
depression
the cause is also not clearly understood
the problem is that psychiatric
diagnosis is difficult very difficult
most diseases like unequivocal
biomarkers diagnosis relies on
subjective psychometric scales and the
gold standard is a subjective assessment
by a trained psychiatrist following the
SC is d s CI D which is a structured
clinical interview for the assignment of
disorders the assemblies the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual for mental
disorders whose latest edition came out
in 2013 so examples of singles assessed
for instance is the organized speech
effective flattened and someone without
training psychiatry I can only imagine
how difficult it must be to subjected
attribute a number say from zero to ten
to how this organise the patient's
speeches or have flattened their
affection
one thing is to diagnose that a patient
has some psychiatric disorder in itself
a difficult task now it's even harder
fight psychiatrists to tell in which
disorder the patient's condition can be
classified for instance
the difficulty of establishing a
boundary between schizophrenia in
bipolar disorder is highlighted but
affected both share positive psychotic
symptoms such as hallucinations
delusions hyperactivity aggressive
behavior and the difficulty didn't go
and notice when the fifth edition of the
DSM was published it came under heavy
criticism big prints of this editor by
in nature
currently the clinical syndromes are
generally understood as separate
categories the patient conditions
classified as belonging either to the
autism spectrum or to schizophrenia for
instance yet those two conditions share
a number of symptoms as you can see here
whose fine-grained subjective analysis
is ultimately the main tool for
classification and to make matters worse
you see that listed as causes here you
see genes and environment which is not
very positive and the criticism goes on
and on so research suggests that mental
illnesses lie along the spectrum but the
fields latest diagnostic manuals to
place them apart the stark fact is that
no one has yet agreed on how to best
define and diagnose mental illnesses and
the problems that biologists have been
unable to find any genetic or no
scientific evidence to support the
breakdown of complex mental disorders
into separate categories so I'll be
talking a lot about diagnosis and
equating diagnosis with classification
but this slide should keep us keep
alerted keep it alerted to the fact that
maybe this is not true I'm just we're
going to classify patients according to
those discrete categories here above all
the schizophrenia or bipolar disorder
etc but it will clear the molecule clear
foundation for this clear separation of
those categories
what we're going to be using essentially
the fact that psychosis effects speech
and then we're going to try to point
apply speech structure by somehow
reducing its immense dimensionality by
main summation reality I mean that the
number of possible speeches is very
large and want to reduce this very
complex space to a traditional numbers
and see if can we we can meaningfully
work with them how do we do this by
using speech graphs so let's move on to
our next topic and topic and discuss a
little bit what is a graph and in
particular what is a speech square well
what is a graph a graph is another word
for a network
it's origin Florentines go back to the
seven bridges of königsberg the stable
problem premise problem in which people
live in that town we're concerned about
this very silly question
can you walk to the city and cross each
bridge once and only once you have those
rear bridges and these land masses so
famous swiss mathematician Leonhard
Euler in the 18th century formalized
this problem by associating each
landmass with a node and each bridge
with an with an edge and therefore
formalizing the situation as a graph
like this and by working with this lower
description from descriptions he was
able to prove that the answer is no to
the question so formally a graph is just
an ordered pair comprising and nodes
together with some set of e of edges and
here you have a favored ship example ABC
three nodes and one edge and this is an
undirected edge compare that with
another graph in which you have again
ABC three nodes and two directed edges
so there are the edges have their
directions also obviously and directed
edges don't and grass have been used for
a long time in physics you can have very
city strings of one-dimensional
--eline admins for instance or two
dimensional structures like this this
lower figure here is graphing a very
thin sheet of example an executor
lattice of carbon carbon atoms in which
each node is an atom and then the edges
represent chemical bonds more common you
have this three dimensional graph which
represents sodium chloride which is the
salt is defining our kitchen
now these record graphs that we usually
see in physics
I mean accounting for all the condensed
matter physics of the 20th century
Francis they're characterized by a
well-defined neighborhood so if these
guys close to these guys and these guys
also close to this guy so these guys are
close to these guys essentially you have
a notion of neighborhood which is
characterized by some definition of
closing coefficient which is high also
the distances are large in the sense
that if I want to go from one one one
site in one part of the network to a
very different site in the other part of
the network I have no other way other
than just jumping by bound by bond edge
by edge and therefore thinking along a
large number of steps to reach the other
end of the of the network now let's
contrast these regular graphs that are
traditionally studied in physics with
the graph that we're selling in
mathematics they are very different so
they were most famously studied by Paul
orders in alpha trainee to
mathematicians who are interested in a
different completely different kind of
graph which is random graphs in which
here you take just a bunch of nodes and
randomly connect them with edges and
these kinds of breads are very different
because they have ill-defined
neighborhood in the sense that if you
have three
for Asus three sites a the neighbor of B
and C is unable of B as well it doesn't
mean as a cell that a is going to be a
neighbor of C so closing coefficients
for these kinds of networks are very low
and on the other hand this is also very
low because you have many many shortcuts
beyond crossing these levels because
they are random so this is our short so
in regular graphs plus a is high
differences are high and even math it's
the opposite well and then 98 there was
the official but I think of complex
networks with this publication a very
important paper by Duncan Watts and
since Strogatz in which they proposed a
very nice model in which you start with
a regular network like this one and
France is a one-dimensional network with
first and second neighbors and with
probability P you take one of those
edges you disconnected and reconnected
real do you just rewire it randomly with
any other side on the network in such a
way that if this probability is equal to
1 you have a complete random graph so in
this parameter B you go from 0 to 1 you
go from a completely regular network to
a completely random Network and what
they did was to plot two quantities as a
function of P please note that this axis
V axis is in log scale what they show is
that for P equals 0 this C here
represents the clustering coefficient
Romania should afford to do some kind of
a well-defined notion of neighborhood
and in in black the black dots are the
distances so
which is also very high in one p equals
zero if you want to go in the leftmost
plot from one one side of the Ring to
the other side you have to just go along
along during no shortcut for P equals
zero if you go on the other hand to P
home equals one this plot what you're
going to see is that classic coefficient
is slow and this is our small just as
you expect for a random graph now
interestingly is that you have some
intermediate region here for which
closing coefficient is large
I mean comparable to that of a regular
graph and this is our small comparable
to those of a random graph so this
coexistence of high clustering
coefficient meaning some well-defined
notion of a local neighborhood some
local orders of the speech with small
distances which means you have shortcuts
to quickly go through a travel course
across the network this coexistence mark
the birth of small networks that's what
small networks are and then they just
took very very different networks film
actors in which two actors actors are
note in those networks and they are
connected if they were in a movie
together power grid or the connectome of
C elegans and they notice that these
real-life networks have businesses which
are comparable to those of the random
versions of those networks
therefore short businesses and classical
officiants which were much higher than
their random counterparts so again large
classical efficient and small businesses
and so all both real world networks are
small networks and this led to an
explosion favorable network in the sense
that deaths since then everything is a
network called a port so
you can see here air traffic Network or
this very other famous paper by but
about this group in which each node this
is the Saqqara missus lvz
protein-protein interaction network in
which each node represents a protein and
the links represent links between a link
between two proteins occurs whenever
they interact physically in this
Saccharomyces television network the
brain of course is a network in so on
and so forth and this then this field is
essentially exploded to become a few
scientific field of its song with many
many publications nowadays ok so now
more or less know what is a graph so
what is this P squared well a speech
graph is very simple it's just a speech
graphs are directed multigraphs that
represent sequential word relationships
in a speech this conception of speech
craft appeared in a second publication
of ours about about this topic in this
the the contact is the following
consider this guy to be a subject in a
psychiatric interview and he's telling
the psychiatrist a dream about a ring so
i saying i was dreaming of a show so we
just picked these words I was REME of a
show and their temporal sequence
represent the edges that you can see
here in this rightmost part of the plot
I say we call them multi graphs instead
of grass just because it may happen that
two different words may be connected by
more than one edge if the patient repeat
the sequence in if there is more than
one wedge between the two nodes then we
call this a multi graph it's just a
technical detail most importantly what
you going to do now is very radical in
the sense that once the speech is
converting to a multi graph like this
one only the structure of the turf is
kept and all the semantics is
disregarded so instead of working with
the grass that I will show you now what
we're going to be working with is this
one
so without the semantic content
and what we do once we have this graph
we calculate what we call speech graph
attributes SJS
which are essentially essentially
numbers that come out of these these
structures consider this example is this
is a true example from from a speech for
patient once you have a graph like this
note that the semantics is already gone
you cannot see a reward here
you couple eight races the number of
nodes the number of edges there are the
number of parallel edges the number of
repeated edges the largest connected
component of this graph the large right
connected component just a maximum
number of nodes in which all pairs of
nodes are reachable from one another in
the underlying undirected sub graph that
is disregarded regarding the direction
of edges you can also calculate the
largest strongly connected component
which is essentially the same as LCC
except that you do respect the direction
of edges so note that this upper branch
here I mean that you see in LCC is gone
from the LLC because although it can
reach the tip from the core in LCC in
LLC you cannot go back because I have to
respect the direction of the of the
arrows you can also calculate one node
loops two node loops three node loops
and a bunch of other numbers so in
particular this ASP average shortest
path and CC closing coefficient are the
same quantities that I mentioned before
the record in this Watson schroederd
paper
you can calculate just a bunch of
numbers here I'm listing here just 1050
numbers
okay so how do we use these as a tool
for psychiatric diagnosis the point that
speech breath attributes are objective
quantitative measures from speeches of
like psychotic subjects so what we're
going to do what we did in this paper in
2014 was the following we had three
groups of subjects one from the
schizophrenia group one called a bipolar
and another for control with twenty
subjects in each group so these are
clinically significant numbers and it's
important to to emphasize that this give
you free and bipolar groups were
composed with of chronic patients so
they had been wall EGNOS by then and we
analyzed two kinds of speeches one in
response to this request by the
psychiatrist please report a recent rain
so we're going to analyze dream reports
and another one which is please report
your waking activities immediately
before the dream so we refer to these as
waking reports
here are some examples of true graph
there emerged from from the scenario
here are some green reports each one
speech for four weeks from each group
this is great fiscal freemium report the
first one and then I bipolar
green report and then a controlled
report you see that there's a clear
difference between sugarfina and by the
way bipolar report in the sense that it
gets the bipolar report gets more
structured more connected somehow
the control seems to be somewhere in
between them now if there's a patient
report on their daily activities the
waking report it's not nearly as
interesting they don't look that much
different anyway anymore and you see
that a particular disk is of cleaner
groove there's not much of a difference
now especially between dream report and
awaken report so the numbers that I
mentioned before
let me show them again here speech graph
attributes are going to reflect the
difference that you just saw just by
looking at the graph and let's see how
this
emerges briefly reviewing the the
methodology about the data so those
patients had a just standard method for
the diagnostic 39 males and play among
females all independently diagnosed by
the standard DSM for ratings and CID
structure interview they've also
subjected to psychometric scales
so once the positive and negative
syndromes syndrome scale and VP RS brief
psychiatric rating scale a psychometric
sales in the sense that psychiatrist has
to subjectively assess features of the
speech of the patient behavior and
tribute numbers to those variables
psychometric variables and interviews
were conducted in Portuguese with
Brazilian subjects and welcome back to
the issue of language later Oh
as for the questions how we're going to
watch the methodology within the
questions we as we asked essentially two
kinds of questions
our speech graph attributes different
for different groups so we applied
standard tests to differentiate them if
the wall is local some rungs on test
with no foreign correction and the
second question is can one use graphs to
classify subjects in this case we just
trained a naive Bayes classifier with
eventually a subset of speech graph
attributes using this structure
interview results as a gold standard
then we cross validate and we assess
performance with this quantity that we
roll appears as a UC which means area
under the ROC curve which essentially
behaves as follow polls if it's close to
0.5 your binary classifier is usually
flipping a coin if it's close to 1 then
it's very good and so result will range
between 0.05 and 1
so what what did we observe here
unfortunately you had a small problem
with this slide here let me jump to the
copy of it which is what exactly is
smaller I apologize for that please note
that what we are seeing here are six box
plots for LCC this is this is one of
these speech graphs attributes the
largest connected component
so Bart gray its schedule FINA group you
have here dream reports and here waiting
reports the light gray is the bipolar
group dream report and waiting reports
and the white group is the control group
again the left part is dreaming part the
right part is waiting reports what you
see here in this plot is that because if
we a group is different from the other
groups only if you use green reports and
if you look at the difference within the
same group price of the control group
they are different this is the the blue
star so the green reports of the control
groups are different from the waking
reports of the control groups in the
this is the the blue star the same
happens for the the bipolar group but
not for the schizophrenia group and this
is the kind of results that you can
obtain just just by looking at one
speech graph attributes measure we have
many of them I'm showing you here 15 of
them and what you see ventually with
some differences here and there is more
or less the same scenario in the sense
that the schizophrenia group is
different from other groups only to use
dream report and the difference between
dream and waking reports occur only for
bipolar and control groups
if you go now back to the next question
which is can always use graphs to
classify subjects essentially the result
is that no matter which figure of Merit
you use to cut to classify a
classification whether area under the
ROC curve sensitivity or specificity you
see that green reports perform better
than wiki reports all the results Dupre
the ones from the previous light and go
back a little bit this one and this one
for the classification are for raw data
we just took the whole speech from the
patient and calculate those attributes
but then there's a question couldn't
that be an artifact due to the fact that
the schizophrenia patients speak much
less than that and if you just look at
the word count you will see the
schizophrenia let me try to go back here
if you go to the World Cup which is the
upper left plot in this of these fifteen
plots you see this case of this
schizophrenia group speaks much less
than the other groups so couldn't be
dissin an artifact couldn't this
classification properties be an artifact
of that so we wanted to control for that
proverb oddity and the way we did this
did this is the following we use the
moving winner with a fixed number of
words so if you assume that the raw data
speech is I walk into a place and I
found my grandma so we now just chop
this speech into a fictional fort in
this case just five words to exemplify
and then move this window and for each
window we have a different set of words
and a different graph and we calculate
the speech graph that you boot for each
of these windows and then average over
the windows this way we can by using the
fixed number of words have always speed
the for control for verbosity if we now
look at 30 word graph what do we see we
see again a difference between
schizophrenia in the sense this is a
fair group and the other ones in the
sense that schizophrenia group is less
connected than the other groups in green
and waking reports the bipolar group is
less connected than the control group
all in dream reports and difference
between dream and waking reports occur
only four by four and the control groups
so now the verbosity explanation is
excluded because all the speeches have
the same coding put verb oddity in the
center they have been chopped by fixed
windows if you now use those thirty word
graft to do your classification again
you see that green reports here in
yellow in orange concern perform better
than waiting reports in almost all cases
you
then there's a question
whether speech graph attributes are
somehow meaningful to us to
psychiatrists because if you just run a
computer program that calculates those
things and gives you some result it will
be helpful if they had anything to do
with something that psychiatry is
already do in the clinic so it actually
is the case that they can be interpreted
interpreted meaningfully what I'm
showing here is the correlations between
speech graph attributes and psychometric
variables so in the horizontal axis we
have a subjective axis of psychometric
variables
in a vertical axis we have an objective
assessment of the speech in the sense of
their speech graph attributes and
color-coded you have the correlations
the white circles means mean
correlations which are statistically
significant and note that you have two
panels one for dream reports and no
another one for Wiggy reports and the
results are for the pointed for dream
reports which is the upper panel here
you have a clear anti-correlation of
some speech graph attributes with
negative and cognitive symptoms so
negative in cognitive citizens are those
columns here in the upper panel such as
certain effects poor contact
difficulty in abstract thinking lots of
spontaneous in speech in advance
emotional retraction and certain effect
in bleep ers so I can only imagine how
hard it must be for psychiatrists to be
trained in order to assess this list of
features that I've just read to you and
yet if you calculate this speech graph
which is very simple the very simple
computer code can do it it correlates
and this isn'ta correlates very strongly
with those exact features so we can have
objective measurements which which
correlate very strongly with subjective
features now for waking reports which is
lower panel you have the correlation
only with general psychotic symptoms
which is why we saw before that dream
reports are much better than waking
reports for classification purposes and
finally there's the question of language
the study was conducted in Brazil so it
could challenge these results and
whether they are specific to people who
speak Portuguese for instance and
so in a first attempt to check that we
have translated all speeches to
different languages using Google
Translate and we run everything all the
analysis in English in Spanish and
French in German and essentially the
results remain so up to now what are
some open questions and more research
that be involved in foot with now
prices can it be used for early
diagnostic or psychosis instead of a
diagnostic diagnostic can it
continuously quantify symptoms severity
using dress attributes or more
interestingly why are dream so
informative because we don't recall them
so well because they are emotionally
salient because they are usually bizarre
that is dreams are not properly anchored
on events shared with no psychotic
individuals because of what I mean there
could be so many possibilities here so
we try to address some of these
questions in our another study of ours
which came out now in 2017 so let's
start with this one can it be used for
early diagnostic of psychosis please
keep in mind that everything that I've
been showing you up to now is with
chronic patients so the diagnostic of
those patients is very well established
by now and when we apply our technique
is just a proof-of-concept kind of thing
right naturally it's much harder to
predict the future so in order to do
that the next election area was as false
we took the interviews with patients in
the first clinical contact with in a
psychiatric interview so as usually this
is a moment of very stressful moment for
the patient for the family very often is
after their first psychotic episode
and they are being interviewed by the
psychiatrist in that situation you have
to wait up to six months of follow-up
before a properly proper diagnose that
can be performed can be reached so we we
ask ourselves can speech breath
attributes open here and this first
click of contact from patients which are
therefore not yet chronically psychotic
can those fish crabs predict diagnoses
six months later later
the data in this case was composed of 21
pages I'm sorry about this this typo
here and 21 controls of those patients
11 and converted to schizophrenia and 10
- bye-bye for disorder
and again we ask the patients to for
dream reports but what we also ask them
to report on negative images positive
images neutral images we asked about
yesterday reports and all this memory
reports so this positive positive and
neutral images image reports were
intended to test the idea of effective
balance effect affective salience of the
dreams and yesterday in all this labor
report were intended to assess the issue
of memory and this is important because
if you you cannot just rely on dreams
simply for effect that in now is 30 36
percent of the schizophrenia group and
20 percent of the bipolar group fail to
recall a single dream so if you'll
realize to the neon dreams you miss many
patients here so this is an example of a
negative image you show this kind of
image of the patient and ask them to
report to tell the story of this picture
this is an example of a positive image
and here's an example of a neutral image
most importantly we also decided by then
of three years of the first after the
previous study to focus on most relevant
attributes only so instead of looking at
all the 15 speech graph attributes three
were kind of enough just edges largest
like a component and largest strongly
connected component so here is an
example of a real speech describing the
negative image I saw a plane crash I
think a lot of people running crying it
was really sad I saw some blood too so
if you convert this speech to a graph
this is the graph that you're going to
obtain and when you calculate the speech
craft attributes you'll find 21 edges a
largest connected component which is
help which has 18 nodes and a large
strong crack component which has 50
notes
one of the questions that we were
interested in answering is the following
how random like psychotic speech
psychiatrists apparently referred to
this speech of a patient when it's very
very disorganized as words sell it in
the sense that it's just a mixture of
words without multiple structure so can
you quantify that how random like it is
the way we we do this is a falling we
took each of the speeches like this one
I'm showing you and just so careful all
the words so if you take this speech the
original speech can make one random
shuffle if you obtain this kind of
nonsense that you see here below and
please note that the number of words is
preserved as well as the number of
Link's is also preserved but the graph
is completely different so you go from
this original graphic doodle in the left
to the shuffle graph in the right and
for each speech we do this a thousand
times so a thousand different shufflings
and we calculate the speech graph
attributes for all of these total
surface as well as for original graph
and now we're going to compare them Amy
at answering this question how are no
like random like is psychotic speech
so what I'm doing here is a following
the red dot represents each the largest
stronger component of one speech from
the skills of intergroup one speech from
the bipolar group and one speech for the
control group so representing three
different speeches with the red dots the
largest strongly connecting point of
those three speeches and in blue we have
the histogram of the largest short
graphic component of 1000 random verses
of that stitch so the close of the red
point is to the blue distribution the
more on the like it is by definition
because the blue distribution represents
all the route thousand random self
shufflings of the original graph so we
use the z score to quantify how much a
red point how close the red point is to
the distribution the z score is just
look at the upper right upper right
corner of the slide is X minus the
average value of x divided by the
standard deviation of X so by definition
by constructional Z has zero zero mean
and it's not a deviation equals to one
so what I'm showing here is one example
you see that the control group in the
right blood the LLC of the true speech
is much it's kind of far away from the
core of the distribution and this gives
a free a group in the left plot it's the
opposite it's right in the middle of the
random distribution so if now we go from
one speech struck from each group to the
whole group to many speeches from each
group we have the following now in the
lower plot I'm showing the histogram of
disease z-score of this LSC
or all the subjects for all the speeches
and what you see if we agree to call
random like zone anywhere when Z is
anywhere between minus two and two
Thunder radiations I mean money 2 & 2
you see that the disk is referring a
group many subjects fall within this
read within this random like zone in the
bipolar group less so and the control
group even less so you can count which
percentage of each group falls within
that random like zone and you'll find
that exceptional group is like 64% as
opposed to 5% in the control group so
yes so this confirms some numbers the
random like nature of the speech the
speeches of some fishes in this case of
FINA group
going back to solid
questions
why are dreams so informative have you
got to do with we don't recalling them
so well or because they are emotionally
salient or what so this is where those
different imaging reports come in handy
if we now compare the again
classification performance using the
area under the ROC curve of those
reports by different categories we can
see that three reports is still the best
thing you can use the second one the
second best is negative image reports
and the third best is positive image
reports so dream reports still yield the
best predictions and neutral image and
yes to the image and all this memories
awesome all this memory they are not so
good so you see that emotional salience
seems to play a role because negative
image and a positive image reports
performing perform well but appenders
there's more to dreams because this
therefore they perform better
you
and we want to go back to the question
that our that I started with in the
beginning in that criticism of dsm-5
instead of diagnostic can this technique
of speech class attributes okay
continuously quantify symptoms severity
using graph attributes that is
can I go away from a QA ting
classification with a diagnosis can I do
better than just classification because
what what if those categories are not
justified so we did this in our 2017
paper what you're seeing here is the
following in the horizontal axis you
have a combination of subjective
variables of the psychometric scales so
remember that and affection at set
cetera
you just have a combination of those
variables and you can construct a
subjective scale a subjective index and
in the vertical axis we have what we
call disorganization index which is a
combination of objective speech graph
attributes which you can somehow combine
in order to have this very strong
correlation with the subjective scale
and please note that this correlation is
very strong regardless of the color of
the dots here which is which is showing
to which group each patient belongs so
they call it very well regardless or
falsification obviously if you want you
can also use the globalisation Index to
make those applications if you want if
you look to the right plot you will see
that this case the fing a group has a
large organization index than the
control group
order by paragraph
but it don't have to so this somehow
allows you to the organization index
somehow somehow allows you to
continuously classify symptom severity
even if you don't have or you don't want
to have a classification
so finally let us go to our conclusions
and some future perspectives things that
we are working on and some other results
the conclusions that is speech graph
analysis seems to be a potentially fast
non-invasive low-cost and language
invariant - for psychiatric diagnosis
potentially able to drive a more
objective search for biomarkers it's
important to remember that not all
speeches are equal for some reason grim
reports are more informative for
diagnosing psychosis and finally we
don't see this as a replacement for
psychiatrists but rather as an auxiliary
tool for them we see them as something
analogous to psychiatrists for
psychiatrists - what a blood test will
be to a general nation it's a useful
tool but it does not replace the doctor
of course naturally this this analogy
will be valid only if the method is
validated with a larger sample so what
else can speech graph be applied to we
have applied two dimension so this has
nothing to do with psychosis and still
in the dementia but for the major
questions issues like distinguishing
between your vaio disease or mild
cognitive impairment the speech graph
taking the speech graphs techniques and
have proven useful and also for child
development in which those beechcraft
attributes have been shown to correlate
well with some theory of mind and really
performances
and what's next well the big question
here is to validate this method with a
larger sample naturally so we have an
ongoing collaboration with Diego's LASIK
in Argentina and visa baisha they are
respected respectively experts in
semantic and acoustic analysis and we
all now have a grant from from bergen
Ingelheim which has included green
reports in the protocol of a clinical
trial for a new potential drug for
schizophrenia this will raise the number
of subjects in our studies from 1020
subject to the hundreds now and this
will make the method much more useful if
it is validated and as a final note the
the software which calculates those
speech graph attributes is freely
available in this website anyone can use
it
naturally it does not give you any
diagnostic but it gives you the numbers
and if you are interested for research
purposes for instance so that's it for
today
I thank you all for your attention thank
you very much